pleasure to see you thank you always a
pleasure to see you guys as well I want
to start by saying how much I enjoyed
this movie it is fantastic I'm sure
you're hearing that from everyone but
before jumping into the film I'm just
curious
something that's been going on the last
two days and I don't know if you've
heard of it is the like certain people
saying that the Netflix movies aren't or
shouldn't maybe be eligible for Oscars
and there's been a lot of talk about
this have you heard about this mhm so
I'm of the opinion just putting myself
there that absolutely any movie made by
Netflix if it plays in a theater should
be eligible do you have any sort of
thoughts on it I don't even know if I
agreed that with the stipulation that it
has to play in a theater I don't know
why a theatrical release is you know
needs to be an element to make it
eligible I feel that sincere filmmaking
at the highest level which is what
Netflix are doing you know they're
working with the cream of the crop of
filmmakers and writers and and then of
course that in turn is is attracting a
very very high level of actor and
everybody else in the filmmaking
community I think that you know it's
it's it's inevitable because of the
political you know people have an
enormous vested interest in maintaining
the theatrical model and making that as
desirable as possible but I think it's
rather unfair that that might prohibit
Netflix from being taken seriously and
awards contention I know if you want to
add anything I mean he always says
perfectly but I mean everything I was
gonna say I mean I completely agree with
Charlie you know even when we're doing
mud bound last year I've always I
thought the benefit to it was that no
matter where you are in the country you
have the benefit if you have Netflix to
go see this movie and it's not relying
on you having a theater in your town
your country your city because there's a
lot of cities and countries that don't
have them and it becomes a big hassle
especially for how I was raised on the
farm my dad
drive us to the theater because it was
25 miles each way so that meant $50 for
a farmer that was trying to skate by
just in gas money then he got ticket
prices depending on how many kids you
have then you know that's the treats and
sodas and everything and when you can
sit you know in the comfort of your own
home and watch whatever Netflix puts out
as many times as you want whenever you
want I think is a huge benefit towards
cinema in general completely agree this
also can I just say one other thing
there's also a causality between or lack
thereof between quality in film in with
theatrical release and its success and
so you know if you're unlucky enough to
be up against another you know bigger
title or whatever you see it out you
know time and time again that it's easy
to get lost and that's the the tragedy
of working as an artist in the world of
film we put you know a year of your life
into a project in three weeks you know
yeah yeah yeah of course you can even
I'm sorry because we men up sorry when
we even up alized all of your time I
just wanted to ask about working with
guy ignores because I'm a huge fan of
his work and a lot of people don't
realize he did second unit on this he's
really known for doing these authentic
practical stunts yeah she just talked a
little bit about working with him and
doing some of the stunt work in this
movie I mean we were warned that you
know he was coming on and and everything
that he did in the latest Mad Max was
incredible it was all the you know I
could think of really when I saw the
film was how daring a lot of these
explosive stunts were and that was
something that really excited me about
doing this the stunts that you're gonna
be seen in this film have never been
done before
Roman our DP make them shine and and
make them look more dangerous than we've
ever seen before I mean everything is is
just I mean it's amazing what this film
has to offer and plus then you got you
know with JC and everybody brought into
the performances like just a lot of
hearts soul
maduk characters who have endeared a lot
in their life in their careers and you
know we just tried to make it as
realistic as possible and guy came in
and just knocked it out of the park he
said like it's it's the new school
that's a reversion to the old school
because he's of the philosophy of if it
doesn't if it's not if we're not
capturing it in camera I'm not
interested he's not a special effects
guy you know and special effect you've
seen this trend of working in film for
15 years or I've seen this trend I
should say where more and more of the
difficulty gets just washed away with
the money hose and there's always gonna
be some special effects guy gonna poke
poke his head out of his tan said oh I
can do that in post you're like well
yeah you could or we could you know try
to be you know try to you know invoke a
little ingenuity right now and figure
this out the way they've been making
films you know for the last 78 years and
figure out how to fix this problem and
do it practically because you know I
find that there's even if it's
imperceptible to the eye what has
happened there's something tricks the
mind there's something that the mind
rejects with with CGI where you just say
it looks like it just happens I just
don't believe that it really did and you
know guy guy is of that same philosophy
he just you know everything we did in
the film is a hundred percent practical
you